[MUSIC PLAYING]
ISE LYFE: I'm a advocate
for social justice.
I believe that all people
deserve adequate food, shelter,
and clothing.
And we are excited about this
play that we put together.
And today I'm going
to talk a little bit
about the play, the
themes of the play, how
we got to the point,
and then bring up
some great folks to help
us keep moving through it.
We have this cool way that
we get through the slides.
It's very magical.
I say, clap.
You clap one time,
and the slides change.
It's pretty amazing.
So we'll test it.
I go, clap.
[CLAP]
And just like that, it changes.
It's very magical.
One more time.
Clap.
[CLAP]
Cool.
Just like that.
So first thing is,
I want all of you--
I know it's midday--
but I want you to think of
any number between 1 and 10.
Don't say it out loud.
Just think it in your head.
Think of any number
between 1 and 10.
Cool.
Got it?
OK.
Now do something,
it doesn't matter.
Add 3 to that number.
Cool.
Now do something crazy.
It doesn't matter.
Add 2.
Cool.
Now do something else crazy.
It doesn't matter.
Subtract the first
number you picked.
With me?
Good.
OK.
Now, do you want to
add or subtract next?
Cool.
Add.
So I want you to add 2.
Cool.
Think really hard, the
number you have leftover.
Just think it.
Cool?
No.
It makes it worse
when you clap for it.
[LAUGHS]
So raise your hand
if you have seven.
You have seven left over.
Look around the room.
Everyone should have seven.
If you don't have
seven, it's OK.
You should though.
I'd like to share with
you how we did it.
Is that cool?
OK.
Cool.
Now, I also want to say this
is the first time in like five
years of me doing this that
anyone has ever said subtract,
let alone a whole room,
which says something
interesting about where we are.
It's a really great thing.
So let's go to the next slide.
That's you.
This is a non-gender
specific stick figure.
This is you.
Cool.
So this is you.
And what did I ask you to do?
I asked you to pick a number.
That's you.
That's the number you picked.
Then I told you to add three.
And you did that.
You said OK.
You added three.
And then I say, OK.
Now do something crazy, add two.
And then I said subtract
the first number you picked.
Remove yourself
from the situation.
Now I know the whole
room is holding five
because all you have
left is what I gave you.
And then I start with
the illusion, well,
do you want to add
or subtract next?
And normally, people, they add.
They say add because
adding is easier.
So I say add two.
Go ahead.
And of course,
you all have this.
Of course the next
slide, it's seven.
Seven is left over.
This is a mathematical
poem that we
build to say that if I
remove you from an equation,
I can make you whatever
I want to make.
And Agnus begins to
address this thing.
Our piece takes place
30 years in the future
and explores in 2047 what the
notion of being an individual
will look like, what is
the future of tech, what
is the future of
privacy, and politics,
all around this high stakes
crime drama that we've built,
as I said set in the year 2047.
Also, when we think about
different communities,
we know what it's like in
different parts of the country
where a certain area is called,
oh that area, or those people
are at risk or under-privileged.
Or the president talks
about the nations
that people come from as
different types of holes,
you know.
And that's a way of taking
away who a people are
and then labeling them with
whatever you want to give them.
So when we started building
out this piece, the first thing
that I did way back in 2012--
I started seeing all
these mass shootings
were occurring, more so and
hearing it in the news more
and more and more.
And I began just
logging these things.
I started logging all of
these different shootings.
And it was like every
other week on the news,
there was this mass shooting.
And then as I looked
into them, there
were ones that were
happening that were not
happening on the news at all.
And I began to really think
about one, how horrible
and how tragic this
was, but then I
started to see a
reoccurring theme in this
that I want to address.
So at the end of
2012, there's a total
of 78 murders that were
connected with things that were
designated as mass shootings.
Next slide.
And then there was
this interesting kind
of framing that the kind of
pacing that kept going on
is that they would say, OK.
We don't know what's happened.
And then they'd go.
OK.
A shooting has
happened, and there
would be speculation around
why the shooting was happening.
And immediately,
the conversation
went to a conversation about
the person's mental health.
Are they crazy?
And what country they're from.
And there also seems
to be this delineation
that the browner a person
was, the more likely
it started going towards leaning
towards are they a terrorist.
The lighter or
whiter a person was,
it went to is a person crazy.
But what was nailing every time
right away was this othering.
There was this
immediate thing when
someone is committing
something like this,
like an impulse to
go, they're not us.
They're someone else.
They're some other thing.
And then there was these
pictures and these photos
that I saw being commonplace.
The one case that we
looked at and really spent
a lot of time breaking down
was the case of the Unabomber.
The Unabomber went to Harvard.
In fact, he was
admitted to Harvard
when he was 15 years old.
A lot of people don't know this.
He went to UC
Berkeley in California
where he got his doctorate.
And after becoming
disgruntled there,
he moves out into the
middle of nowhere in a cabin
and with no heat,
electricity, running water,
he begins building
bombs and committing
terrorist acts for years.
He's was one of the
first people that the FBI
considered to be uncatchable,
like verbalizing it.
They didn't know how
they could catch him.
He writes a manifesto
and he threatens
that if "The New York Times"
and "The Washington Post"
doesn't publish his
manifesto, that more people
are going to be hurt.
And it was published.
And in it, he starts
talking about--
and he has these crazy,
sick things that he's doing.
And then he starts
talking about technology
and the threat of technology
and that if we don't stop,
the environment is
going to be impacted
and that people sitting
around tables, families
are not going to
talk to one another.
He starts talking about these
things about how technology can
negatively impact the world.
And of course, he's doing
these horrendous things
and committing these
horrendous crimes.
His sister-in-law notices a
line in the published manifesto
of language that he
uses and goes, hmm.
And his family makes
a hard decision,
and they contact
the FBI and say.
I think that my brother
may be the Unabomber.
And he was caught.
But before he was caught,
media and news outlets
and the Academy,
professors, researchers,
were talking about this man.
He's a terrorist,
but he's brilliant.
And there's all this
intrigue around him.
And then they pulled
him out of the cabin.
And when they pulled
him out of the cabin,
he didn't look like this
kind of H&M model ad
thing in the middle here.
He looked as we know him.
And right away, he's crazy.
His psych evaluation, after
terrorizing this country
for over a decade,
was five days long.
He was labeled crazy.
He didn't have a full
trial by his decision,
and he was sentenced
to life in prison.
Our piece deals with--
also, of course, and what he was
doing is crazy and horrendous.
But it deals with
the physicality.
I was asked to point
what's up with my hair.
And you're going to
see pictures of Agnus
in a little bit that
will get into that.
Next slide please.
Recently, in Vegas
of course, tragically
less than a year
ago, I was in Vegas.
I called the
co-writer right away
because I saw this
horrible shooting that
happened in Vegas.
And because they
didn't know anything,
they pulled up an FBI
wanted ad from his father
and started having a
conversation-- with his father
was said to be psychotic.
And again, that was
really interesting.
Not because we're like, oh.
Don't call these
people who are doing
these things crazy, crazy.
Part of our concern is does
it prevent these things
from happening when our leading
action is to just call someone
crazy and lock them up.
And we see this in different
areas of crime in this country.
We've seen for years when
there's root causes to violence
in inner city communities.
They'll go, oh.
Those folks-- it's not crazy.
It's like, oh, they're gang
members, or oh, they're thugs.
And we're going to lock them up,
and that's going to end crime.
And of course, that
doesn't play out well.
And now when we see this spike
in these mass shootings that
are predominantly
occurring by white males,
the conversation is
like, oh, they're crazy.
And there's no
conversation about what
is the root cause of what's
going on with these young men
and men that lead
to an inability
to deal with their
frustrations and then lash out
in these horrendous ways.
Next slide.
So I was trying
to figure out how
I was going to build this
piece, what I was going to do,
and I thought of
who I could contact
that had some type of insight
or was building in writing
about the future,
writing about technology,
engaging in different
conversations.
And we started building
about it right away.
This happened over the
course of two years
that we built around
this play to figure out
how we could do something
that was compelling
and build out something
that was honest
and produce it here in New York.
We went to every talk and
conversation and forum
about the way that technology
impacts the workplace,
the way that technology impacts
our environment and the food
we eat.
We saw amazing forums like the
Glass Room here in New York.
I don't know if anyone saw that,
but it was a really incredible
exhibit here.
So in building Agnus,
we knew that Agnus
had to look different.
He had to not be on the grid.
He had to have some
critique of government.
We wanted to make sure that
he had a ferocious intellect.
And in building of this
character, he was scarred,
and he was also
accused of a crime.
And that will create
all the elements
that we needed to
portray something
that will invoke in the
audience the feelings that we
have about wrongdoers in
this country and the biases.
Next slide, please.
And Agnus was
created in this way.
And this is me after 2 and
1/2 hours of make-up tech.
We're excited to show you some
other behind the scene photos
that just came in as we've
begun loading in the tech.
Next slide.
So we knew that we wanted to
pick where we might be headed
to inspire a vision for change.
So I do a lot of work
inside of institutions,
whether it's in the
Academy or in prisons.
And it's really
interesting seeing the way
that prisons are being built,
the way that prisons are being
monetize, the streamlining of
building out and anticipating
budgets based on crime rates,
and the way that they're
privatizing prisons.
And it's funny.
When we started
building this set--
Kirn showed me a very
interesting thing this morning.
Kirn, what is this?
KIRN KIM: It was the
original concept sketch of--
[LAUGHS]
ISE LYFE: Kirn does all
this great work with us,
and Kirn was the
first person that
helped us kind of conceive
the project as far as what
it would look like visually.
And to Kirn's credit, this
is our initial sketch.
And all of you, I want
you to be inspired when
you see what this turned into.
Start to dream from
anywhere because it really
got somewhere.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ISE LYFE: Next slide.
Agnus, in the play, he's an
odd man in both appearance
and personality.
He's volatile.
He's being accused of killing
the governor of California
in the year 2047.
Next slide.
One thing that we're
really proud of
is that along with our
play engaging these issues
on the stage-- and we'll
talk about this a little more
with our moderator--
we're engaged in community
organizations here in New York
City that are actually doing
on the ground work to build a
better future for us and not
by giving them free tickets
to our play but by saying,
hey, when we're not
in this theater,
this theater is yours for
you to do specialized events.
And we'll talk about
that a little bit more.
So we wanted to share that.
So these are taken
from our stage work,
and we have an
incredible design team
that has helped out
with building out
this futuristic prison
and what it can look like.
And we wanted to share some
of these images with you.
Next slide.
We have an amazing
cast, an incredible cast
that's helping us bring
the story forward.
And as we roll into
the thing, I think
we have other slides of just--
what this is in lighting tech.
So this isn't even the official
final makeup take on Agnus.
But one thing that's very
interesting about the process
is as we're having to test
lights and bring forward this
futuristic thing, working
with different paste and tones
to get the look really right--
but all of this was to address
that theme-- and the
next slide please--
of Agnus looking different.
You can just roll
through these, Kirn.
And our whole set is
projected live here.
This is really great.
Because as we move
past papers and pens
30 years into the
future, ways that on
stage that we can depict
the future of what
our devices will look like.
And of course, this
is the type of stuff
that you are all
doing in this forum.
And as we wrap up, go ahead.
Let's see what's left.
Khalil will be
joining us shortly.
We just have the coolest
kind of vibe and team
bringing this story forward.
Next slide.
We want you to know, of
course we want all of you
to come see the play.
Please come see the play.
We're right off Broadway.
We're just two blocks
from Times Square.
And as we close out,
we're looking forward
to the conversation that
we're going to have with you
and answering any questions.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ISE LYFE: Cool.
I would like to
invite up two people.
First, I want to
invite up Elz Cuya.
This is Elz Cuya.
Elz Cuya is a great
collaborated with us for Agnus
and responsible for helping
us bring the community
organization that
we're working with.
She's deputy director at
North Star Foundation.
We're really excited
that she's here with us.
And Khalil Kain is an
actor in our piece.
Please welcome Khalil
Kain and Elz Cuya.
ELZ CUYA JONES: Hello, everyone.
Thank you for having us.
Hello, Khalil.
Hello, Ise.
I'm going to moderate
a brief conversation,
and then we'll open
it up to questions.
OK?
Khalil, if he looks
familiar to you,
it's because you've seen him
in the seminal work, "Juice,"
starring Tupak Shakur.
And it's a very special day
because it opened 26 years ago
to the date.
So we're really excited
to have him here.
We just heard from Ise.
I wanted to ask Khalil--
tell me why this work is
important to you personally?
KHALIL KAIN: I
got sent the play.
I took a look at it.
Right now, I don't know.
From an artistic
standpoint, I feel
like if we're not
doing something that's
making some sort of impact
politically, societally,
what are we doing actually?
There's a responsibility
for imagery
for what we're putting forward.
And as soon as I read the
play, I was like, wow.
OK.
This is really-- it
has a point of view.
You may agree with it.
You may not.
But it definitively
has a point of view.
I was intrigued right away.
So I met-- actually met here--
with Matt and Ise.
And we discussed the project.
I know what I read.
I wanted to get a
sense of actually
what Ise and Matt had to say
concerning this position.
I think the play
is really intimate.
It's powerful.
If you come see the
piece, the theater,
you're going to feel like
you're in the room with Agnus.
It's a little chilling.
But I knew I was going to
be a part of something that
was making a
statement, and that's
kind of where I'm at
right now as an artist.
So I decided to get to work.
And we've been working hard.
So I'm excited for
you all to come.
Anybody who comes see the
play, please come join us.
ELZ CUYA JONES: Opens tomorrow.
KHALIL KAIN: Yeah.
ISE LYFE: So, Ise, I
heard what you said
and what you said
about art that makes
a statement about something.
You wanted to bring community
organizations to the piece.
And something that you said
that really resonated with me--
I'm a fundraiser for
social justice movements
around affordable housing,
police accountability,
LGBTQ rights, immigrant rights,
food justice, et cetera.
Ise wanted to bring a
piece of art that was
accountable to the community.
So with this piece that you
wrote along with Matt Werner,
can you share with me--
just speak more on
that about being
accountable to the community.
ISE LYFE: Well, I think that
part of what Agnus is about too
is that in that
whole othering thing
that we have
conversations around--
these communities and
those communities-- and I
think that in that, there
is an inadvertent kind
of sidestepping of
people, particularly
who come from spaces
that we don't understand
or that we don't know about.
And so we wanted to write
a play and a piece that
made the audience be
confronted with that.
And our piece
doesn't really give
a way to escape from the fact
that we have ideas and notions
about people or that
we have comfort zones
that we rather kind of stay in.
And so in the
writing of the piece,
we wanted to be
accountable to folks
who are othered for
various reasons,
whether it's because they're
incarcerated the way that Agnus
is, whether it's because
they look a certain way.
And then in our
production of the piece
and inviting organizations
out, we felt like--
there's this common
thing in the arts,
particularly in
theater arts, where
people kind of go and they
have an alternative experience.
And then they go, this
is informing my work.
And then they go, and
then they write a work
and they present
it to people who
don't come from the
experience that inspired
the play in the first place.
And doesn't even
really nod to them.
And so by having people be
able to come into the theater,
be invited into the theater, be
incorporated in our storyline,
and our plot was our way of
being accountable to that.
KHALIL KAIN: I have to
say, doing this work--
we've been in rehearsal
the last two weeks--
even before that, even
just digesting the play,
being part of that
other can be painful.
So a lot of times it's easier
to sort of lean away from it as
opposed to lean into it.
And doing this work has
helped me sort of identify
and sort of hug my otherness--
being able to identify
with Agnus a little more
and understand that
this is happening now.
It was happening before.
And the way we frame
it in the play,
it will be happening
in the future
if we don't change something.
ELZ CUYA JONES: I just want
to share with you briefly
a few of the
organizations who will
be using the space that Ise
and Matt so generously offered
to the community organizations.
Black Transmedia
is an organization
that is shifting
folks' image of what
it is to be black and trans.
Black Lives Matter
Week of Action--
they're launching their
Week of Action at the space,
and they're bringing the
values of Black Lives Matter
into the schools.
And also Just Leadership will
have an event at the space.
And Just Leadership,
their mission
is to decrease the amount of
incarcerated people by 50%
by 2030.
And there are many more
organizations using the space,
and those are just a few.
So Ise, tell me when
you created this piece
with Matt, what is your
biggest hope and your biggest
vision for the work?
ISE LYFE: My biggest hope
and vision for the work
is that people who are
responsible for building
the future, that are building
what the what the world will
look like in 30 years, are
doing it from a holistic space.
My firm does this project with
the Science Center and NASA,
and I was really
excited about that.
In one of the talks from
one of the astronauts
who's been to the
Space Station twice--
he says, in 50 years, there
will be commercial mining
in outer space.
And the room went, whoa.
And then I went, whoa.
So that means that we're like,
oh, we're going to the stars.
Let's get this money.
You know?
[LAUGHS] And I
smiled about that.
I was like, well, it's
interesting, you know.
And I think that
those of us that are--
whether we're building tech
or building political spheres
or building art--
that we're inspired to go--
in 30 years, I'll
be 65 years old.
How old will you be in 30 years?
I'm asking you.
No.
You here with the glasses.
Yes.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: 56.
ISE LYFE: Yeah.
That's a wild thing
to think about.
So we have this futuristic
play, and we'll be here.
And I hope that we evoke
that thinking in people.
ELZ CUYA JONES:
One of the things
that really intrigued
me about this piece
is hearing about how
Ise conceived of it.
Can you tell the audience
about your experience sitting
in the LA courthouse watching
arraignment after arraignment
and how that impacted you?
ISE LYFE: One thing though
that was interesting
when I started building out
the piece and thinking about--
I said, I'm going
to go to courtrooms
and watch how it's done now so I
can think about what it's going
to look like in the future.
I live in downtown Los Angeles.
I went to the
courthouse right there.
People of all different
races and backgrounds
coming in and dealing with--
whether it's families
or people who--
and I started
seeing the families.
But I noticed I
wasn't seeing any
of the people who were being
accused of crimes in person.
They were doing live
feeds from a county
jail arraigning people.
And so even a jury is looking
at people, not face-to-face,
not there, but
through a live feed.
Of course, it takes
the human piece out--
KHALIL KAIN: Dehumanization.
ISE LYFE: There's
dehumanization,
and there's a disconnect in it.
And I'm sitting here
thinking, like, wow.
We're building this
piece about the future.
And I was like, whoa, this
is happening right now,
like right now, where
the judge stands
and then a woman that's
being accused of a crime
and she's in a room.
She stands in the room.
I saw this, and I thought, whoa.
And that was heavy to me.
And the other thing that
was very interesting to me--
and this story should be
told a million times--
is how many people who are
not connected with the case
at all-- they're not interning,
they're not taking notes,
you're not building a play--
concerned community members who
believe in democracy and peace
that just come and just
watch and are concerned.
And that blew me
away too, that that's
an untold story, that
there's people who really go.
I saw people who get
jury duty, and they want
to be a part of the process.
And when you talk to
them, it's not like, oh,
I want to lock somebody up.
It was like, I want to make
sure somebody gets a fair shot.
And I learned from
watching that.
So I think that--
in wrapping up my
answer to you--
I think another
thing is that when
we talk about the
future, whenever
past, it's always
nostalgia for those days.
In every book, play, and
movie about the future,
it's like donn.
What is it about the
future that scares us
to that when we write
about it or think about it,
it's like whoa?
And I think part of it is that
what we don't know is scary.
And so our play is an
opportunity to talk about,
hey, you know, we might
be headed down this road,
but also there's glimpses in
our play around where it could
go in the right direction.
And I feel good about that.
KHALIL KAIN: Yeah.
There are some of
the things that we
don't know that can be
scary, but then there
are things that we do know
that are scary, very scary.
I mean, honestly folks,
it's a legit fear of mine
to be incarcerated.
The odds of me actually
getting locked up
are greater than
you might think.
And this is like something
that me as a man,
as a human being, when I
leave my house every day,
it's something that
I remind myself of--
be careful.
Don't get in trouble.
Do not get arrested.
Do not get locked up I
mean, my whole adult life--
this is something that I get
up, shower, have my coffee,
get ready to walk out the
door, be careful today.
I mean the chances of being
arrested in the United
States of America--
I mean we incarcerate
more people
than anybody on the planet.
So it's something
that I've avoided.
And it's funny because--
be careful what you ask
for or don't ask for.
It's a legit fear of mine.
So I got an opportunity to work
in the prison system mentoring
young felons.
I said, no because I
didn't want to be--
he does this work.
I didn't even want
to be in there.
I didn't want to go near it.
And of course, what do I do?
I get cast in this
play, and I have to--
I'm serious.
And it's like experiencing this
every day during rehearsal--
again, I go home.
I wake up.
It becomes reinforced.
Because through art,
it becomes real.
Like this is happening.
This is happening.
We're writing about it.
And then we're looking
30 years in the future.
And it's--
ISE LYFE: It must
really be a trip for you
too because Khalil
plays the warden
of the prison in the play,
which is a whole other thing.
KHALIL KAIN: It's a lot.
ELZ CUYA JONES: Another way
that all of this dehumanization
is very real, particularly
here in New York City--
one of the organizations
that I fundraise for
is Communities United
for Police Reform,
and in December, the City
Council voted on the Right
to Know Act.
It was a bittersweet victory
because one half of the law
was passed, and the
other half was not.
So the part that was a win
was now police officers
have to let the person know
that they have a right to not
consent to a search.
And if they don't speak English,
if they need a translator,
they have a right to know.
And they have to know that
they understand that they have
a right to not be searched.
The part that we
lost, which was so
disappointing to the
200 organizations who
fought for this--
the families of the
victims of people
who were shot by police--
was that police still don't
have to identify themselves.
Can you imagine?
My son is black and
a police officer
can be like, what are you
doing, and hold their gun,
and not say who they are.
And about the
unknown being scary,
and then they're not even
being held accountable.
So it's really real
in New York City.
KHALIL KAIN: So what can we do
to get that sort of education
out to certain
marginalized youth,
that they know they have the
right to not be searched?
I mean these are things
that these kids don't know.
They don't really know
what their rights are.
I mean, I'm an adult. I don't
know what all my rights are.
ELZ CUYA JONES: Many
community organizations
do trainings all the time
and get young people in there
to know their rights.
Know Your Rights trainings
is what they're called.
And organizations doing all
kinds of different things
from organizing street
vendors, to immigrant rights.
It's not just organizations
that are working
on police accountability.
They're working on
this so that everybody
knows what the deal is.
It's really awesome.
ISE LYFE: And I
know we were going
to open up for questions, yeah?
ELZ CUYA JONES: Now is
the time if any of you
want to come up to the mic and
ask questions of the artists.
ISE LYFE: No pressure.
ELZ CUYA JONES: OK.
While you're thinking
of your question,
I want to bring something up.
You have someone
on your team, Kirn
who is working on the
slides back there,
who has a very unique
experience that has informed
much of the production.
Can you talk about that?
ISE LYFE: This is Kirn Kim.
And Kirn is a great staff member
at my firm here in Los Angeles.
And when Kirn was 16 years
old, Kirn was tried as an adult
and sentenced to life in
prison when he was 16.
And part of what our work
has been about in the piece
and beyond that is
figuring out how
do we address and make
sure that people really
know and understand
the gravity of what's
happening within our
justice system with children
and how children
are being treated.
And I hope there is a space for
us to address that and speak
to that.
KHALIL KAIN: There are a lot
of countries that just will not
try a child as an adult by
law because it's just not
morally correct.
Here, we do.
And there's something
wrong with that.
ISE LYFE: Any other
questions before we close?
AUDIENCE: Thanks for
coming, and I look forward
to seeing the play.
So I have a comment
and also a question.
So the comment you mentioned
about how the future scares us,
and I wanted to--
as a longtime reader
of science fiction--
we used to write science
fiction that was hopeful.
And somewhere in the 70s,
that got unfashionable.
And so everything is
about scary and awful
and how bad it's going to be.
And I think we actually
have a dire need
for hopeful imagination
of the future
so that we have
something to aim for.
And the question I have--
I notice that your
title character, Agnus--
so that's traditionally
a female name,
the character
appears to be male,
and his name is an
anagram for Angus,
but it's also agnus
as in agnus dei.
So I'm wondering
which layers of those
are actually
relevant to the play?
ISE LYFE: The part about him
having a woman's name comes up
in the play.
And there there's also
a Latin derivative
and a Greek
derivative of Agnus--
and it's a cool thing--
you can Google it--
being a reference
to lamb of God.
Yeah.
And in naming Agnus, I
thought of all these things
he'd be made fun of.
and he talks about
how he's tormented
about his looks, and then
his name and all of that.
When his nature, as we believe
all of our nature to be,
is to be made of the
starstuff, to actually
you come from the universe.
We look at babies, and
everyone loves babies.
And then somewhere in
there, these things
come up that shape the way we
name and make fun of people.
And so I was hopeful
that in giving him
a peculiar name
that people would--
this question has come up--
that people would search for it
and ask.
But it's to be a lamb
of God or the universe.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ISE LYFE: Thank you.
Appreciate it.
AUDIENCE: Questions, but
I'll ask the second one
after you answer the first one.
Just based on the visuals,
I am taking that this
is more of a dystopian future.
ISE LYFE: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: How has
your interaction
with Googlers shaped that
perspective of the future?
ISE LYFE: Whoa.
That's a great question.
It is a dystopia that we
built with hints of like--
I used to read those "Hardy Boy"
books when I was a kid where
it's like, you can go this way.
And in talking and
being around folks
that are Googlers and also folks
at some of the other really
large tech spaces, what I find
is an untold story of people
who really, really,
really, really, really,
really care about the
future and building things
in a way that is
provocative and concise.
But I think the big secret is
the love in the room in all
of it and that people
are being thoughtful,
not just from
their Googler mind,
but also from
their Google heart.
And that there's heart
in the conversation.
So that that's changed
my perspective.
And then I think it also has
revealed an opportunity though
to inform the mind minded
people in the world
and be reminding of the heart
and social aspects of the world
and humanity.
And I think we
separate that, right?
We think about societal
humanitarian work,
and then we think about
tech business work
as if they are these
two separate things.
When of course, they must
be entirely integrated.
If you think about the campuses
that train us and teach us,
there's a divide there, right?
There's the social work
folks, and then there's
the tech business folks
as if this isn't really
a cross-pollinated world.
And so those are the things that
I've taken from the experience.
I appreciate your question.
AUDIENCE: I'm just
curious as a playwright
how did you decide
2047, 30 years,
being really specific about the
future and just saying, yup.
I'm calling it.
This is what it's
going to look like.
Did you wrestle at all
with, well, I don't know.
It might look like this.
It might not.
How did you decide just to--
ISE LYFE: The co-writer
and I thought through--
the whole line in
the beginning was
we don't want to start
dealing with like robots
walking around on the
streets and flying cars.
And we also wanted to talk
about something that people
had to be accountable
to whether it's
you're being accountable
to it because this
is the world that you will
leave behind for your children
and grandchildren or you
have to be responsible for it
because you would be like,
well, I'm going to be here.
We wanted to run that line.
And then it also gives
a great opportunity
to speculate in some dark ways
but even in some humorous ways.
At a point in the play,
there's a reference
to Attorney General Kardashian.
And that's crazy but
could legit happen.
A Kardashian could run for
office and have a shot.
That's wild, but
that could happen.
And so it was just to
kind of keep it up on us
and give it something that
people could be accountable to.
It was fun.
Thank you.
KHALIL KAIN: I don't know.
I think if you're 22, 30 years
from now seems like, whoa.
A lot could happen.
But if you're 52,
you realize that
in 30 years how much changes.
There's not like
this seismic shift.
And in reading the play,
the first time I read it,
I was kind of intrigued.
I was like, this
makes sense to me.
It's not far-fetched,
and it's informed
by what has come before it.
I know, for me, 30 years ago--
I'm kind of shocked.
30 years ago where I
thought we would be now,
I'm really sort of shocked
at where we're at in reality.
I had a completely
sort of different feel
as what we'd be doing
and where we'd be at.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Can you briefly describe
what type of set
you have to get
this message across?
ISE LYFE: Oh.
Cool.
Yeah.
The forefront of the
set and the set design
is around these projections.
So we built a set
out of projection
that began on that
yellow pad there.
But it's all projection.
The set is projected.
And there's these huge
frames that cover the stage,
and I don't want
to give it away.
But the frames do cool things.
The set is minimal and also
very powerful and impactful,
particularly with the way the
projection and the sound works.
And one thing we learn in
this process and working
with the designers is all of
the different elements that
tell the story-- from the
costumes to the makeup
to the projections to
when someone said, hey,
we need a sound designer.
I was like, someone
is designing sound?
And yeah.
They come in and really
design the sound environment.
And I think people are going to
be really impressed with what
we've done in this space.
And then also, as Khalil
referenced and Matt touches on
often, is that you'll
notice that when
you're in our theater, you
feel like you're in this world.
And it's a really cool thing.
AUDIENCE: In social
justice reform,
are there any pieces of
technology today [INAUDIBLE]
ISE LYFE: The question was--
in social justice reform,
is there any apps or
technology that we find
to be interesting or useful?
ELZ CUYA JONES: One
thing that I've seen
is that day laborers
now have an app so
that when they're getting
picked up for construction work
or whatever, they can
register the license plate.
And other workers,
they've built a database,
and other workers
will let them know,
this person actually
pays you and this person
will leave you out on the
street without getting paid.
Also, of course, with police
brutality, the fact that we all
have cameras on our phones.
Now there's an ability
to immediately send it
to the ACLU or your local ACLU.
And what community
organizations are
doing around the
illegal surveillance.
Since Homeland Security folks
are surveilling Black Lives
Matter and people who are
doing social justice work,
they're organizing themselves
to train themselves to amp up
their security because they're
small nonprofit organizations
with very little resources.
So how do they do their work
and not be illegally watched?
ISE LYFE: And I've seen
a really great, cool app
that food justice
workers are using
that can evaluate the produce
that's in their local grocery
store and hold accountable
that grocery chains distribute
fairly and evenly the
quality of produce that
goes into the grocery stores.
Because one thing that's
happening is certain stores get
the beat up fruit and
vegetables and other ones don't.
So I appreciate that
question because we've all
seen the way that that's a
driving force [INAUDIBLE]..
Thank you.
ELZ CUYA JONES: I really want
to thank Matt for arranging this
and of course writing
the piece with Ise.
Thank you, Ise.
Thank you, Khalil.
Thank you, Google.
We'll see you next time.
We'll see you at the
theater tomorrow.
ISE LYFE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]